let's bring in uh andrew brandt
columnist for the mmqb
business of uh sports podcast former
packers executive
and uh we wanted to have andrew join us
we want to look at teams short term long
term
let me start with the cowboys andrew
thank you for joining us
cowboys long term given these contracts
their whole setup here um are they built
for success in the future
you know they've got the highest cap
charge in the nfl right now at dak
prescott's 31 million dollars they've
invested a ton at
positions you don't normally invest a
ton in and i'm talking about receiver
and running back
they have invested on their offensive
line but it just seems like they've
allocated resources in areas that
are not analytics don't show they're
good for long-term success
uh they haven't invested long term in
the quarterback
they've invested again in receivers and
running backs
the amari cooper contract seems like an
an extraneous one now
after drafting a receiver number one
yeah i would say that's a team that's
not using resources the way you would
think
you know starting quarterback left
tackle
corner shut down corner uh premier pass
rusher
you know it's not working for them
they've overspent at positions they
didn't need to and they've understand
the positions they need to
give me the like the texans i've brought
up i don't think they're in a good
situation at all
they have they have no draft capital
they they
they've already shelled out some big
contracts here uh moving forward
will the texans job be a coveted job for
a head coach
yeah as long as it's just a coach you
know bill o'brien was in a could have
been
positioned to fail dan because coaches
have to motivate inspire get the trust
of players get him to run through a
brick wall
general managers have to be detached and
cold and cool
and unemotional and putting him in the
job of general manager i mean
other gm's dan smelled blood in the
water you know he's trading clowney and
paying half the contract
he's given away hopkins for inferior
value he brings on tonsil
for two number ones and doesn't do a
contract giving him the leverage to get
an amazing contract
laramie tunzel's offense uh leads the
offensive line
in contracts by a wide margin and that's
not going to work
so they need someone fiscally
responsible in the gm
role you know when i was at the packers
we had mike sherman for a while coach
and gm and he would come to me dan and
say
hey andrew i need to make you the bad
guy
i totally get it you know you can't be
holding the purse strings for these guys
i get it you know the only one to do
that really well is belichick because
he's just
so detached emotionally from these
players it works for him
what about the vikings they were they
were so close to going to the super bowl
and that seems like so long ago and they
used to have
you know an elite defense there why
didn't they just stay with case keenum
at a bargain
price and bring instead of bringing in
kirk d cousins they
they're paying dalvin cook now long term
what do you see with the vikings yeah
they've i mean i think they're probably
the most disappointing team in the
league and i know there's a lot of
candidates including the cowboys but
this team went all in not once not once
but twice
on kirk cousins they could have let the
contract run out this year
see what happens but they re-upped him
at a huge number
almost better than the number he had
although less guarantees going forward
and i'm like
why you know why nothing and kirk
cousins is a great guy
but he's being paid at elite level not
once but twice
by the team that you know obviously paid
him in free agency now they've done it
again and of course cook paying the
running backs
listen you know how i feel about running
backs and everybody's saying well derek
henry's proving it well derek henry was
on a franchise tag he could have proved
it on that as well without
committing long term we're going to see
how these elliott deals and and
camaro deals and this deal play out but
i just think with running backs you've
got to hold your powder for other
positions
yeah if the giant would you resign
saquon barkley if you're the giants
it's going to depend on what happens you
know it's like
do you resign any running backs i
wouldn't contract i would not
i mean mccaffrey seems to be in a
position by himself but who knows
and these are the kind of things now
camaro was staging kind of a hold in
you know being being some angst to the
front office
when he was in that deal and he got the
deal but
you know mix and i i just don't see it
and it's
i did it the packers you know with
dorsey levins and i'm on green i'm like
listen
i love these guys some of my best
friends on the team but i couldn't
justify it because of the short shelf
life of the position
what kind of position are the jets in
you know this is the gm coach not coming
in at the same time mcagnen
spent a ton of money i mean cj mosley
and of course le'veon
all these deals and then the new gm
comes in you know like these guys
you know and then coach didn't even like
levy and bell
so you talk about dysfunction i mean
they're paying
six times more for levy and bell than
the chiefs are this year
they're gonna have massive cap dead cap
which is really the true marker i see
dan
on bad management of contracts is dead
cat money
like all the money you're paying for
guys that on the cap that are not there
any longer and the jets leave the league
there
so they have to again like we just
talked about with the texans
they've overspent they got to underspend
and listen cap
management should not be hard right now
you've got half your team at least
for teams like the packers a lot more
than half your team on rookie contracts
so say each guy makes a million dollars
cap that's 30 guys and 30 million in
caps so you got 150 million 170 million
for the other half of your team that's
not hard
really that's not hard so if you do bad
contracts that's what comes back to
haunt you not paying the quarterback or
not paying your premium positions
that's the fallacy people have about
contracts if the jets end up with the
number one pick in the draft
yeah any question about what you do with
that pick
you know if you if you determine
lawrence is that guy i think
we have the example now in arizona
where they traded josh rosen after
picking him 10th in the draft and they
brought in number one quarterback
if you determine it's that guy you do it
now you're gonna have tremendous dead
money
you know on darnold assuming you move
them you have to move them you can't
have them as a backup
but yeah i just think where they're
where they're going
unless they determine donald's that guy
and maybe you know
there's gonna be difference of opinion
there but you know now you're talking
about
losing on purpose that's really hard in
football it's easier in basketball
well that's why i said if i'm jets
ownership i keep everybody in place if
we're this
last thing i want to do is make a change
and have somebody come in and might
spark this team a little bit
with the jets like if you're going to be
bad be bad where
there's a pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow but
as i've said before just because you get
trevor lawrence
that doesn't mean that you've you've you
know
fixed everything with the jet if i'm
trevor lawrence would you could you see
him do what peyton manning did
and payton came back for his senior year
at tennessee
and the jets were on the clock with the
number one pick in the draft
could you see trevor lawrence if he
thinks the jets are going to be the team
to take him he would come back to
clemson for another year
i don't know you know or poland eli
manning
eli manning andrew luck you know andrew
luck chose stanford over carolina that
year they took cam newton
um i don't think he's the personality
that would do it but you never know when
agents get involved
and they want to you know leverage the
situation as much as they can i think
that's a possibility
with agents i don't know the kid it
sounds like it's not something he would
necessarily do but let me just say this
about losing on purpose
they're bound to win a game or two the
thing about tanking in football you're
right you're right keep the
keep the talent level where it is and
not bring in someone to raise the talent
level but
you know in basketball you know you can
tank in football what are you going to
do stop blocking and tackling you know
it's like you just have to make a front
office decision
that you're playing inferior talent
and maybe that's what you know that's
the definition of taking in football
you're not going to tell the guys
hey let the guy run for a touchdown so
it's much harder but i see
if he's an otherworldly talent you know
even though it's not basketball lebron
or zion
that is something to prove because
having been there with brett and then
bringing in aaron and seeing what aaron
could do those cup
first year i'm like we're good you know
that's the best feeling in pro sports
when you've got the guy
to take you to the future you know
whatever you do first year if you're six
and
ten or whatever seven and nine but if
you got the guy
you know you're golden that's what you
want now do the jets think they have the
guy i don't know but that guy seems like
the guy when you're in the room and you
know that aaron rodgers is there
and you already have farve and you
decide
he's fallen into our lap that we have to
take him
not exactly the case with jordan love
with the packers they went up
to get him i think they thought the
colts were going to take him so they
went in
and got him instead of taking an
offensive you know
a weapon for uh for aaron what
was it universal that everybody in the
packers draft room said
let's take aaron rodgers even though he
had brett favre
absolutely not you know i'm in the
middle i've got the coaches on my right
they're pulling they're like we
coaches want someone that's going to
help them right away yeah coaches are
judged and we had
you know a staff that was kind of
tentative with mike with ted thompson
coming in
had you interviewed aaron rodgers oh
yeah yeah of course he was on number one
on our draft board
he was the only guy left you know when
we got to pick 24 is the only guy in the
first round left so everyone's
you know the coach is saying we can't
andrew we can't we can't we can't
and the management are saying what do we
always say trust the board
trust the board he's the best player
we're not going to dip into our second
round grades
so now it's this okay i get him on the
phone we got 15 minutes the poor guys in
the in the green room
the caterers moved everything and i call
and i think i'm calling the agent i'm
like mike and it's like no it's aaron
i'm like gosh
okay aaron can i talk to mike and mike's
like can i are you gonna take him or you
can take him i'm like just hold on
because we were gonna see in those
12 minutes probably the longest 12
minutes of erin's life
if with phone rings and we get an offer
we can't refuse whether it's two-twos
the future one
and i'm like okay yeah i just gotta keep
them on hold
who called and dan
that phone never rang
and i watched this guy every week for 10
years and i'm like
what if that phone rang you know the nfl
could look a lot different that phone
never rang we took them we got the lambo
field party under us a thousand people
i mean it was just they hated it
and brett calls the coach and brett's
age bus calls me and they're like what
are we doing and
yeah and then three years dan three
years where
aaron's camp is wondering if he's ever
gonna play brett's camp
is like hey andrew you know what it's
like coming in every day with your
replacement sitting next to you
i mean this this was hard to manage now
they're going to do it with jordan love
aaron seems a lot more kind of open to
it
you know but at you and i know right now
there's an expiration date on aaron
rodgers and the packers which i'd never
thought before april but there is one
who were the packers going to take if
they didn't take aaron rodgers i don't
know
maybe you know maybe uh
a receiver ayuk or somebody but
you know listen we never we took a
receiver one in 2001 javon walker and
then it's been all
you know lower round receivers and it's
worked out for them but
that's the packers you know you're not
going to jump the board
you're gonna just play the board are you
are you more likely to draft a running
back first round or a wide receiver
first round
good one i would guess a receiver yeah
i would guess uh you know you get a
special receiver at a young position
you know running backs you know look at
the packers aaron jones
sixth round fifth round and up you know
you find him
and you know the real i hate
i hate to be a running back because you
have this three-year draft eligibility
rule dan
so your most productive years are really
unpaid and then if you get your rookie
contract which is unpaid as well
compared to big contracts i think that
we should give running backs three-year
contracts in the nfl
like their rookie deal could only be
three years
and i think the nc the nfl rule about it
for three year eligibility should not
apply right
i know i know we've seen that oh i'm
seeing
jason campbell was taken right after
aaron rodgers
roddy white three picks later would you
guys have taken roddy white
no he was a pretty good wine receiver
i remember that draft board i mean we
wanted demarcus where so bad
we wanted marcus spears we wanted uh
derek
johnson with the chiefs we wanted uh
even david pollock we were looking at
and they all are gone
so we're looking at one guy you know and
yeah we didn't go in thinking god we
need a quarterback
let me say this the packers have been
the luckiest team in the league right
franchise quarterbacks for 30 plus years
it's going to be
and the whole idea is franchise
quarterbacks now for 45 years
if love's the guy yeah so i get it you
know i was there 15 years ago i get it
that's what they're trying to do
yeah they reach though you know
it's not my way you know they reached
i mean if this guy is
you know but but again he has to play
people say well the rogers playing so
well they're just no no no
you you take a first round quarterback
he plays
whether it's in one year two years or
three years he will play and rogers will
be somewhere else
it's always great to catch up with you
thank you andrew we appreciate your time
always a pleasure dan andrew brandt
columnist for the mmqb
businesses sports podcast and former
packers executive